[Music]
you know I mean apart from you guys
being you know knowing the brutality of
stand-up and the immediacy of that and
having to be on because as everybody
knows what he's notoriously fast you
know he shoots from the hip he's like a
freight train I mean there were so many
theater animals you know bobby cannavale
ian and wonderful sally hawkins and
peter and alec you know of all done
theater and so there was a sense that
everyone understood the subtext of the
piece and so and I think that's what
what he does is he 97% of his direction
is in the script and it was I mean he's
an impeccable dramatist it was
beautifully structured the the the
screenplay and so you know none of those
pieces are going to disappear and so you
can trust the structure of the piece and
then he throws that open to the actors
to bat it back against each other so
it's about jasmine
how did you find her Center and find
where she lives
no Center that that's the thing it's
just I mean she's different things with
different people and and you know she's
she's a grand character with a with am a
tragic floor and then that is there her
epic delusion and there were so many
things that what he didn't didn't seem
to think were particularly interesting
or unusual but you know the fact that
she changed her name at an early age
from Jeanette to Jasmine the fact that
she's adopted so she's estranged from
her biological beginnings and and she
said about establishing a fairytale life
for herself and that in fact was a that
in and of itself was a fantasy her
marriage was based on a fallacy so
there's no center there's nothing for
her to grasp on to and I think that
that's um you know that's what sent her
into freefall is that what do you guys
talk about that no I think he puts it he
puts all those clues there and Jasmine
herself is searching for clues as to why
she's ended up where she's ended up I
did watch that that extraordinary
documentary on woody you know to see
what other actors experiences had been
Anne
and uniformly people were saying you
know you get one take if you're lucky
and he's not particularly forthcoming
with his direction verbally on set so I
was prepared for that but I don't know
how else to perform if it's not in
dialogue with other actors I mean what
other actors do completely influences
the way you respond I just ask what he
questions and he answer them
so in fact there was a dialogue I said
how would you do it mystery Allen and he
would say well and he got quite Blanche
like actually in his response he said
well if I was playing the part you know
so it was um what makes it absurd and
tragic is that you've got characters who
got such conflicting wants and needs and
they're all hell-bent on achieving them
and and they're utterly incompatible so
um
yes Ellie and I did a lot of talking
about where we'd come from and why she'd
left and at the base we wanted to
establish something where that there was
a genuine love between the sisters it's
just that their their circumstances and
their life choices and their the
opportunities that have presented to
them was so radically different I'm
interested in creating characters that
are thrown back at the audience to like
or dislike to judge positively or
negatively I don't believe in
sentimentalizing a character but I
suppose an empathetic connection I had
with her is that she's not someone who's
ever had any sense of agency I mean
she's given that over to her husband and
you know there's a myriad of women who
who do that because if you know their
role modelling has has suggested that
that's the way you behave with men but
you know I think it's I kept thinking
she keeps talking about I want to go
back to school I want to become
something she actually wants to claim
and discover an identity she just
doesn't know where to begin and she's
such a you know a heady cocktail of
guilt and rage and grief and loss and
fear and you know apart from you know
being on a cocktail of xanax and Stoli
martinis you know and so I think that
that's she's desperately searching to
find out who she is number one when I
Met Sally it was at the beginning
I didn't even really get to meet her it
was at the beginning of a scene the
scene where were in the hotel room we
come home like after the party and she's
undressing me whatever is that the first
thing you showed that was the first
thing I had a film with her and you know
she had that real you know accent that
East Coast accent and you know I thought
she was great at it but then after the
scene after what he said cut she started
talking to me and from with her British
accent I'm going you're not from here
you know she was like how do you do that
I mean you know and then to see Kate
work the way she does and and how into
her character she is I mean they're just
chameleons they just become that person
and it's really you know it as a perform
as an actor it was great for me just to
watch them do that I mean it's pretty
unbelievable to see we've we all have
big show business histories here but you
know from day one no matter where my
career went up down in the middle I
never like got used to it and went you
know this is what I am this is who I am
it's always know you know because you
know I always believed in you know
keeping belief and what you do as a
performer and always for whatever reason
the the fire and me just constantly
burns to do more and it's very inspiring
when you wind up doing a film like this
number one I came over to Kate last
night because you know you know
obviously we haven't been hanging out
that much you know but I had a tiger you
know I've seen you in so many things but
this this was just like a stellar
performance it was like unbelievable for
me to watch and I'd pick up on other
things than even the lines like you know
there were a few times in the movie and
I don't know why I love it so much
because I don't know if it was in the
script or it would just happen but her
instincts when for instance when she
gets out of the car when she makes Peter
Poulter decide she drops a bag for
whatever reason is crazy as she's going
she's picking up all the little things
putting it in the bed happened a couple
times in the movie you did it with Alec
when he was telling you about the girl
he's in love with
and no matter what jasmine takes the
time you know to get all those things
from a big and it's just that's like a
comics instinct to something goes wrong
on stage so it just looked very like
incredibly natural it was just like
really happening like you're not even
watching a movie and you know I say it
in front of us a behind the back I mean
just one of the greatest I've ever seen
you know I'm in all of her
[Applause]